around the world many countries are
heavily reliant on wheat imports and
prices have long been high but russia's
invasion of ukraine has triggered
another price shock currently a ton of
wheat is at well over 300 euros peaking
at a record 450 euros just recently and
only coming down somewhat since then
russia and ukraine are major producers
and among the world's leading exporters
close to a third of global wheat exports
come from russia and ukraine
the wheat goes mainly to the middle east
turkey and china via the black sea port
of odessa which has been under attack so
the wars disrupted logistics chains
farmers are joining the fight so the
next harvest is uncertain
some of those who've stayed behind can't
use heavy machinery with shrapnel in
their fields all bad news for places
like lebanon
pizza bread like this is a crucial part
of the day for people in lebanon it's
often known as the loaf of the poor
because it has always been affordable
for everyone
but now things look different
prices have shot up over the last couple
of years of economic instability and now
people are scared the war in ukraine
could make things even worse
people are panicking they are rushing to
buy bread those who usually buy a bag
are buying four or five instead
in the afternoon we even see some
bakeries that run out of bread and you
sometimes see cues in other bakeries
like we had during the war
these people are at the sharp end of a
compound crisis a country in economic
collapse pays with foreign currency to
import wheat amid global inflation and
now
there is war in ukraine
before october 2019 this bag of pizza
bread cost one and a half thousand
pounds and that was the fixed price i
have just bought this for 11 000 pounds
the price rise is mainly due to
lebanon's ongoing political and economic
crisis but now global events are playing
a part too
the price of wheat and therefore flour
and therefore bread
is rising around the world because one
of the biggest sweet producers is
ukraine the war there is putting lebanon
in a difficult situation
wheat importers are looking towards
places like france and germany
some are even looking towards the united
states but all those options are further
away than ukraine meaning
greater transport costs
ever since the private sector started
importing wheat it was always from the
countries around the black sea mainly
ukraine and russia the last two years we
imported 80 percent of our wheat from
ukraine
it's a global crisis that is affecting
importing countries
because of the inflation in wheat and
fuel
it will affect wheat prices its
transportation
and it will reflect on bread prices
the 2020 explosion that trek bay would
poured destroyed the huge silos that
held up to four months worth of grain
currently there is enough wheat for a
month if people can no longer afford the
loaf of the poor
hunger and political instability will
follow